there seems to be quite an interest in
many of the primordial deities that
existed in ancient Greece and one of the
most requests that seems to be Tartarus
now as of all of the primordial deities
there has always been this debate as to
whether they were actual physical beings
or manifestations and personifications
of ideas and places one exactly Tartarus
came to exist is something that changes
depending on the source that you're
using has he had himself buddies that
Tartarus was a third primordial deity
following chaos and Gaea you also
believe that Tartarus was the father of
the monster - in the ancient Norfolk
tales Tartarus was considered with a
deity and a place located in the
underworld
he was also considered to be the first
ad to have existed it was then from him
that light and the cosmos were born
Tartarus the place can be found deep
under the earth even deeper than Hades
Collison Tartarus and the underwater
confused at the same place but Tartarus
can almost be described as the abyss
below the underworld which does in fact
emerge of Hades in certain places the
easiest way to distinguish between
Tartarus and Hades is that Hades is the
place of the Dead where they go to rest
or be punished once they have been
judged by a course Minos and
Rhadamanthus know according to Plato
these three judges amongst us harden the
fate of those in Hades also decided
which of them would be sent to Tartarus
over the years Tartarus would serve as a
place for those who committed
unspeakable acts against the gods or
humanity Tartarus essentially became a
prison the earliest account of this beam
when Cronus rose to power as the king of
the Titans
he immediately imprisoned Hackett on
quarries in the Cyclopes within Tartarus
because he felt they could possibly ever
throw him Cronus would then place a
dragon outside the entrance of Tartarus
to act as a guard but Zeus would later
kill this dragon when he traveled to
Tartarus to free its prisoners and ask
for their assistance during the war
ironically enough Tartarus would then
serve as a prison for many of the Titans
when Zeus a nice fellow Olympians would
eventually emerge victorious with the
people of ancient Greece unable to
punish their own Kings that task would
then fall to the gods and goddesses who
would intervene sending the guilty to
Tartarus these fallen Kings included
Tantalus who killed his own son and
later served him to the gods during a
feast King exile who pushed his
father-in-law into a bed of burning coal
and then attempted to rape Zeus his wife
Hera and of course King Sisyphus who was
known for killing guests and travelers
breaking the cardinal rule of
eyetality we can simplify Tartarus to a
dungeon or prison for those who are too
powerful to have conventional methods of
punishment forced upon them my personal
interpretation of Tartarus is as the
fiery pit below the underworld I've
never really seen Tartarus as a physical
deity just as I've never really imagined
Gaia to have been a woman more so
symbolic of the earth and mother nature
I see Tartarus not as the deity of the
pit or the prison but the prison itself
much like the rest of the primordial
beings there is no real correct answer
as most of it just comes down to
personal interpretation some people view
Tartarus as a deepest region in the
world
the prison of the Damned and others see
him as a deity that represents the
region itself but in the end they refer
to the same thing a deep dark abyss that
few will ever return from Tartarus is
definitely an interesting point of
discussion and one that I'd like to hear
your thoughts on do you consider him to
be a deity or a place or perhaps both of
them let me know in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
you